a esta hora de la economía en francés 24
es con jorge hurtado jorge buenas noches
buena charla iniciamos economía de un
seguimiento al precio del petróleo que
continúa al alza así es y esto luego de
una jornada mega volátil tras el anuncio
o la posible prohibición de la
importación del gas ruso y el petróleo
ruso de parte de europa y de eeuu la
referencia prensa situó en 122 96
dólares el barril esto tras haber
alcanzado los 139 13 dólares durante el
día un aumento que no se veía desde la
crisis financiera de 2008 mientras la
referencia estadounidense cerró en 119
dólares el barril los precios mundiales
del petróleo se han incrementado en un
60 por ciento del inicio de 2022 lo que
mantiene la preocupación por el
crecimiento económico mundial y la
estanflación así se le llama cuando
ocurre una combinación de dos fenómenos
económicos el estancamiento de la
economía y la inflación o el aumento de
los precios los precios del níquel se
dispararon un 90 por ciento del oro
superó a los 2000 dólares la onza y el
trigo alcanzó su máximo en 14 años
y mientras tanto se alistan más
sanciones contra rusia por la invasión a
ucrania así que bueno la unión europea
ya prepara un nuevo paquete de sanciones
precisamente para evitar que moscú de
alguna forma llevada a las sanciones que
ya fueron impuestas se espera que este
martes se den a conocer las nuevas
sanciones de parte de la comisión
europea así como un conjunto de medidas
para reducir la dependencia del gas ruso
pero en europa hay posiciones
encontradas al respecto el ministro de
exteriores de lituania dijo que no se
puede pagar el petróleo con la sangre de
los ucranianos mientras que el primer
ministro de bulgaria dijo que apoya las
sanciones pero que buscarían una
excepción si entre las propuestas está
suspender la importación de petróleo y
gas ruso varios senadores
estadounidenses también presentaron el
esbozo de una legislación bipartidista
para prohibir las importaciones de
petróleo ruso en estados unidos algo que
mantuvo muy movido a los mercados
bursátiles escuchemos que dijo la
presidenta de la comisión europea ursula
von der leyen we see the town water
violan ses entre racing y konami vemos
turbulencias en la economía rusa pero
vista la evolución de la situación en
ucrania
mérida del kremlin contra los civiles
mujeres niños hombres evidentemente
también estamos trabajando en más
sanciones que puedan estar justificadas
nuestro segundo tema será la energía
tenemos que liberarnos del gas del
petróleo y del carbón ruso
off you can dance of las casas o el
alcohol
bien jorge y mientras tanto también en
moscú los ciudadanos ya comienzan a
sentir el alcance de las sanciones así
angela allí decenas de personas
encontraron las puertas cerradas de
muchos comercios donde compraban ropa o
productos los gigantes de las tarjetas
de crédito visa y mastercard
suspendieron su servicio en rusia
netflix también lo hizo y snap chat
desactivó su mapa público de ucrania por
motivos de seguridad de los usuarios la
otra red social más popular del mundo
tick tock detuvo las nuevas
publicaciones y transmisiones en vivo en
rúsia esto porque rusia aprobó una ley
de noticias falsas y bloqueó facebook
twitter y youtube en el país escuchamos
un poco qué opinan los rusos al respecto
dejaré de ver mis películas favoritas en
netflix dejaré de comprar mis marcas
favoritas porque ahora están en todas
cerradas dejaré de viajar y mi profesión
ni siquiera es necesaria porque ahora se
ha implantado una estricta censura no sé
cómo voy a trabajar
pero compró medicamentos locales no
necesito en absoluto los extranjeros los
muebles tampoco los necesito tengo de
todo y que más estas sanciones no me
afectan en absoluto que teníamos durante
la época soviética nada y vivíamos
tranquilos y en paz
básicamente no me gusta todas las
tiendas los concesionarios de autos
están cerrando estoy en contra de esta
guerra y estoy a favor de que se negocie
cuanto antes para que se acabe pronto
jorge los indicadores de la jornada
empezamos con wall street que hoy vivió
su peor día del año esto por el
recrudecimiento de la guerra en ucrania
y el temor a sus efectos en los mercados
mundiales más la presión alcista de los
precios del petróleo las acciones
europeas terminaron fuera de los mínimos
de la sesión ayudadas por un repunte del
43 por ciento en los valores energético
ya que el precio del petróleo supera los
130 dólares durante el día y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo caído por
las compañías aéreas y el sector
petrolero en medio de la preocupación
por este aumento histórico del precio
del petróleo en jorge pues te agradezco
y nos vemos más adelante feliz noche a
nuestros televidentes siguen en france
24 ya volvemos
[Música]